roux voilà bien nos invités viennent
d'arriver pour l'instant ils sont de dos
car il regarde la corbeille
alors je voudrais vous demander nous
avons le temps de faire un humiliant
jean pierre v le temps une fois nous
avons eu le temps que vous êtes d'accord
les monégasques oui bon alors je vais
demander aux invités de se retourner je
vais on commence avec evelyne je vais
vous laisser mon micro yvelines alors
pas de oui pas de nom pendant une minute
et chacun votre tour d'accord voilà j'ai
choisi qui je veux donc à bon passe
dessous non rester là pour rester là
yvelines voile imaginez dans la fri et
répète la peau fille alors on va jouer
au ni oui ni non avec evelyne qui veut
commencer
madame vous vous levez miss levé vous
pas de wii pas de nom pendant une minute
d'evelyne quand vous voulez bonjour
madame
mais vous avez bien manteau vous avez un
peu froid dit oui madame alors alors
suivant la carlos maintenant bonjour
madame oui on voit alors qui veut jouer
avec carlos leitao
adam se monte à vos wii avec quart
d'once pas de wii pas de nom pas de nom
bonjour l'homme
ça fait plaisir alors si vous attends je
vais descendre sim gelée par là bas on
prend une candidate pour d'autres
missives une dame de préférence six mois
pas toujours bien sûr madame z joue avec
sim
allez venez la porte pas de nom c'est
parti madame bonjour madame donc
huissier bonjour madame vous voulez vous
avez failli tomber la presse qu avant
vous allez bien ça va est ce que vous
croyez que le ciel va se maintenir au je
crois notre beau soleil
vous avez dit oui non
et bien non je pense que nous n'avons
plus le temps maintenant alors nous
allons applaudit encore une fois nos
invités evelyne grandjean carlos sim et
je me demandais à régis policiers le
dernier carton de l'émission